because that's what happens is men that
cheated on me or did me wrong or didn't
want to commit to me
they all come back around at some point
and they all drop in my dms and i'm like
this is like really interesting
something
probably but i don't sleep with them but
they they still go so my really really
toxic ex we broke up three years ago
he's the one that told me that he had
cancer i dropped my job my home my
friends i i literally gave up i got
really unwell because he was
awfully cheated on the whole time i
really allowed him to treat me really
badly and i'm like you cheated on me you
didn't respect me you ended things with
me
why are you still messaging me three
years later
when i know you've got a yell but he
knows as well that i'm sex yeah sex and
i'm like wow i think i think from the
relationship that it sounds like you've
had
he
believes that he can still
control you
he does that so you you answer though
don't you
oh you don't no so well
so i posted a picture on my instagram of
me in like some lingerie it looked good
i was thirst trapping i was seeking
attention no shame in this game and he
went oh that's my saturday sorted as in
i'm gonna masturbate over you and i was
like you you've got a girl this is not
appropriate and then he went i'd love to
see more pictures and i went yeah there
are more but they're not for you and he
was like oh okay and i was like to be
fair yeah i should just ignore it i
should just and so every time i reply
i am giving him a bit of power and i am
yeah do you think that women have an
expiration date on dating
like do you think there's any urgency to
like find a husband sooner rather than
later
um i
yeah i think like i wouldn't like to say
yes but i think so i think yeah even
you've got like the whole you're going
to have more options now than well they
say that men get better with age and
women
at some point too but yeah but they say
that that's it you know men are allowed
to be a silver fox whereas women have to
get botox and dye their hair and again
you've got like the whole biological
like well it's just like we get we get
that attention immediately so like i
remember being like 15 16 and i was like
why is everyone paying attention to me
now you know braces came off and [ __ ]
like
and but like men don't have that like
they're like invisible to the world so
it's like a trade-off yeah so so right
now you there's there are things you've
admitted on this show
that you get special favors and stuff
because you're a young 100 percent
audience yeah right but men don't get
that for the first half of their lives
so like
people will cry and say it's like not
fair but it's like the most fair thing
ever and it's a very small percentage of
men that actually become silver it's not
the majority most men don't even get
half that level of advantage that most
young attractive women have and i think
well then as a man gets older it then
comes to um
what you can provide and an older man
you're going to maybe assume you've got
more
finances you've got more xyz i don't
know
i think men i actually don't i find
women a lot more attractive than men
like categorically women are a lot more
interesting than me today over here oh
yes yeah even though men are a lot more
attractive than men
but it's as a man gets older you do just
assume like you're probably going to be
more ahead in your career you're
probably going to be so that itself is
more attractive
but it's i think i think that like men
i don't know i'm not really attracted to
50 year olds like i think i can be like
i'm not physically attracted to them i
mean mark ruffalo
i would call him daddy any day of the
week what's what's what's the oldest you
would
actually consider for a husband
uh
15 20
years old
no years older
no i dislike you no
so maybe 45. so you would consider a 40
year old guy seriously for marriage and
so yeah if you had no kids [ __ ] most of
most of them probably have children but
like if you look good no kids
sign me up how about you i would really
depend because i know some like men who
are post 50 who are really they're
running like iron man's triathlons so so
if they were like they want to marry you
start a life with you you'd be open to
that
do you know what i'm gonna be real
honest i i would i would be a gold
digger if there is an 80 year old man on
his deathbed who was like
i i would do it i would do it for that
easy life
there's there's no limit age limit for
you
i mean realistically yeah there is like
that's me just like
kind of like being realistically i'm
like
oh [ __ ] i don't know because there's a
lot of [ __ ] to go in there like even
like health even like how open are they
to travel how committed are they to
their job how like no all those things
are there i'm just saying the age what
what's the age limit
i don't know i don't know i don't know
she doesn't know i like i'm trying to
think the perfect age
i prefer guys my age but usually i think
like they're usually more like looking
for something casual yeah so that's why
i like guys in their mid-30s not because
i'm more attracted to them but just
because like they're kind of
like i don't know they're not in like
the casual yeah you know it's weird like
i
can get butchered out here if i say this
um i feel like for a mental thing i
prefer women who are older
to actually talk to on a on a on a
standard basis i'd say is generalization
but then
if it's just casual fun then
to be honest it's kind of if she's
attractive
i have a heart take i think girls peek
at like 18
at the time
yeah
yeah rose martial says like 22-23 i
think
personally for me
i would i would say and we're talking
general i would say 24 25 because that's
when i say she's still like if she was
hot at 22 she's not gonna not be hot at
24. do you know what i mean but she's
probably more mature and i value that i
think that 18 year olds look the best
because most girls gain no more
most girls don't gain weight in college
i know but they just look like most
girls get like beer bellies
in college i just think i just think
like because i'm at that age where girls
who hit on me are around that age yeah
and i find it weird because they just
look like children to me yeah
whereas i'm like now i want to i want a
woman yeah a young woman but i want a
woman you know what i mean like i feel
like i don't know that's what that's why
it's like
yeah i just yeah i couldn't i could like
i couldn't get a girl who looked
incredibly young looking i'd feel weird
mm-hmm
i know some guys love that [ __ ] but
that's i don't know i don't think i
think 18 year olds nowadays look like
they're 25. oh they did [ __ ] guys
okay
i'm like
what the
i don't know
but
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't go lower than
23 though he wouldn't go lower than 23.
yeah
i remember the day that old guys got hot
it was really weird it was like i didn't
see guys i did when i was 21 or 22. i
was going on dates with a guy that was
30 and i just couldn't get past it i was
like i can't he's so
old i remember like thinking like
oh he's 30 like that's so old and but
now i remember being like 24 i mean like
okay are 40 year olds attract our dad's
hot
yes oh my god it was it was so weird it
didn't happen till like 24 23 maybe i
was like
oh this is strange
this is strange
i have a question for both of you is
there a diff well
what would you say is your
dating age range but then your sleeping
casual sexual age range
so for me i would personally happily
sleep with someone who was like 21 but i
wouldn't date someone who was 21. i
wouldn't like
yeah i cannot
i look for it all this like it's the
same to me
okay like
i don't know seriously okay no not
seriously like yeah like oh like between
casual and serious
uh
i'd say casual
anywhere between
23 to like
i mean i've dated a woman in her late
40s before so i'd say like 23 to like
48. if we're talking seriously i need to
see what she looks like
i need
let me see they won't see it they won't
see i won't show them i won't show i
need to see
well that's what because i know that for
a fact they should be right
if i wasn't going to be serious about
someone i definitely the younger they
are i'm like it doesn't matter
let me see i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna keep the mic this way and i'm
just gonna hope that you why you still
got it for kip's sake i'm gonna oh is
that a dog
why you still got it why you still got
it squeeze me
[Laughter]
is that is that is that a thing don't
guys keep like albums of all the nudes
they have well if i if i end things with
a guy i have to i say to them i'm like
respectfully i would like you to delete
anything i've sent you but
[Music]
i know they're friends
until they get a new phone
or they get or if they get a girl that's
like i need you to delete this but i'm
fully aware that if i ever send
something i'm fully aware
i'm fully aware that if i send something
to someone that i'm and i don't advocate
for it at all but i'm aware that one
they're probably going to show some of
their male friends i know that i know
that it's happened to me before that
they'll be like this is the girl i'm
sleeping with this thing i'm dating i'm
well aware that if i send something
that's it
uh it's it goes back to
consequences if i send a nude photo or a
promiscuous photo i am well aware that
it probably will not just stay
in his phone or with him and it probably
will not end
comments on this
on what on the album
listen ladies
if you send a guy a nude photo it is on
his phone forever that's all i'm going
to say and i say this i say this in my
videos you guys do guys show each other
their girlfriend's nudes not their
girlfriends just like random hoes so
yeah so if they're okay so if there's a
girl that he's not taken seriously yeah
she sends him a nude he's shown it to
his closest i'll be honest he is
but if it's his girlfriend no [ __ ]
way that shit's his
no way and even if it was an ex because
it's like
yeah it's it's a respect thing isn't it
it's a respect thing
what about girls because they get dick
pics all the time what do you guys do
with that nothing personally i literally
can't [ __ ]
i'm like dog picks over dick pics when
people send me a dick pic i do the fake
like oh wow i literally don't give a
[ __ ] i don't think i've ever gotten a
dick pic not like not like a one i asked
for like i've had yeah yeah yeah
but then have you have you ever felt the
need to ask someone no no no that's the
weird thing
i mean never say never but
again if we go back to
like majority and exception i think
majority of girls do not give a [ __ ] and
so if she's asking for a dick pic she's
probably just trying to inflate your ego
or act the way she wants you to act yeah
and same with threesomes though i know a
lot of girls who are like oh i've had
threesomes and oh wait let's oh wow what
the [ __ ] she looks good
[Music]
okay